Alhamdulillah.
Muslim.
My respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters, I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala of Almighty God be
on all of you.
It's an honor and pleasure for me to be
part of this Islamic
part of Lancawi Islamic International
Conference 2025. The theme of which is
Islamic
sustainable development goals.
And as some of us may be aware that in
the United Nations
they got together
and
they had a meeting and they decided on
17 sustainable development goals to
improve this world. So they had a plan
of 15 years that by 2030 they will
improve this whole world for humankind
and they pointed out 17 sustainable
goals.
So this conference is held the first
time
on the theme Islamic
sustainable development goals
and what United Nation had discussed
alhamdulillah has already been mentioned
by Allah subhanana wa ta'ala in the
glorious Quran and in the sayings of our
beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the authentic a hadith.
So in this conference
we have mashallah 17 speakers and each
one of them will speak on one
sustainable goal and what Islam what
Quran what had to say about it
and I'll be speaking on the fifth
sustainable development goals as per the
United Nations that is gender equality
and the topic of of my talk is
true and practical
true and practical gender equality and
Islamic solution.
I would like to repeat the topic of this
talk of mine is true and practical
gender equality and Islamic solution.